All right,
with 33 minutes to spare,
Mario-- why is the train coming
?
Right away,
grades are also going to work on a holiday,
aren't they finished
?  If you can't keep up with too many bugs,
Mr. Suzaki, you're so kind. It would be nice to have more people sooner
.
Mr. Suzuki,
if it's almost 30, I'm sorry for everyone
.
There's this, and
it's not a lie lol
[music]
than
ana yeah yeah yeah
ni
[music]
panoram
yeah yeah
[music]
ana
ran
teame yeah yeah yeah [music] yeah yeah yeah ok
input and output for all classes
After that,
I created a document and a correlation diagram from the source code with Auto Document, and then I
identified a full-
fledged bug.
Suzuki
Hey, I'm from a certain bar world, and the au almost said to play third. Hey,
we've been teaming up for half a year, but there's no
mistake.The difficulty level is too difficult for beginners.
I
didn't say I didn't like it because the main target wouldn't play if
I lowered the difficulty level.  I wonder if it's okay to add an annihilation bomb as a bonus.
I'd like to say that,
Mr. Suzuki, please implement it.
Wait
a minute. Right now, I'm working on an mmo rpg for smartphones, so please
get the client's
ok first.
I don't have time to fix
it, so I
'll call yououtside to
confirm right away Well,
[music]
Maybe I
should make it a mesh
?  I don't know what you're saying In
this case, I wonder if I'll quit for the time being
Okay, I'll move to the police
.
But I'm glad I wasn't mistaken for a kidnapper
Thank you very much a If you're a
beautiful mother
ffl I'm
afraid
Mouri
I haven't been home for three days.
Is it
possible
to create something
like her?  This is a bug report.
Hey,
if you have 6 atomic bombs that can store items without charging,
I dealt with it earlier, but it's ffl's
inventory
.
There's no star bird.
Par 5. I
was afraid of what would happen, so I finished it by e-mail
.
There
's a treasured sword called a patch
I think I can hear the users yelling at me, but I
don't know what to do.
I can't sleep at all
c It's time for clothes,
company slaves and Bara Baba,
now
sleep is my
assistant
Tiichi  I'll buy it
Well,
isn't it unusual to have a dream of rejuvenating?
Or
rather
, it's already a mixed feeling of world ffl Is it overworked Bakuma
? You can control it just by getting money.
Valley of the valley
Is this crack the valley of the dragon?
Oops, it's because of the human race
There are about 300
players around level 50 They're not opponents that a level 1 player can beat in a thread
.
Did you hold me in the middle of the day?
ran
[music] It's the
basics
If you were spending your days immersed in work like Japanese people who are known as working ants, you
shouldn't be so depressed that you want to escape somewhere other than here
I felt that being busy was rewarding  It's
true, yeah, yeah,
f
th,
uh,
it's morning now, the
distance is too close to me, so I couldn't get an effective hit.
Do you mean fighting?
Well, as expected, even in a dream, this kind of thing is tough Hey, there must
be a way to quickly end it Logout or something,
ah,
can't you log out or save?
Come to think of it, I don't feel any pain
before I know it, which means that my maximum physical strength is increasing, and
that's
not all.
All of the voodoo ability values ​​that were
there are maxed out and
maxed out.
But I wonder if this is
suitable Hmm, I wonder if I should enable this.
I don't have enough, I ca
n't cry when it comes to crying
Is it okay to talk about this much?
I didn't approach the danger and sealed
it I'm thirsty I'm thirsty
loot car
Gay gay Lizardman's corpse is also a loot I
'll
take out this water for the time being it's
big
eh
th
good It's the first time that water tastes this good
eh
Mugen  I
don't know how it works, but it's convenient.What's in the
north
?Ugo,I have a
lot of money.
Curse
, my heart is stimulated while I'm lost huh,
[music
] is
less than I thought it
would be.  It's like a normal zard version
, so I wouldn't want to run into it
Then maybe I should take a break and see if I can get through
it I'm bored even if I'm here all the time
Come to think of it, I haven't felt anything like this lately I don't know how long this dream will last But it
looks like it's going to be a
good place to take
a breather
Alright let's go  Chestnut
auc This
seems to be the closest
[music]
There is an army of about 100 people The level
is the highest 31
If there is no average, it's surprisingly low
Teyandi Wyvern I
wonder where it is
tan
[music]
I wonder if you're going to cast a
normal resistance skill at the beginning, when your
endurance is high, it's
cloudy
[music]
The power of level 310
is amazing I'm sure there must be an army over there.
I don't know what you
're talking about edel and the end result ah ah ah
voodoo Othello It's
a place that's moving I'm here If
you take April for whaling
Pass it freaky Listen to the
depth I'll lose to the momentum of ever
and be
palleted Attract  He doesn't slow down by throwing a spear
Most of the temple is blocked by a Wyvern company Is it
simply a hard evasion or a level difference
with that?
Ore
ren
tee
ana
[music]
Our party was in Miyamae, a
mountain
of bamboo
.
nini
silver wall
satome the taxi is still maximal ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah!
]
ni
[applause]
me